votre rendez vous dédié aux juniors à
cette semaine nous vous proposons une
activité manuelle à faire en famille le
1er décembre c'est jeudi prochain et ce
jour là n'oubliez pas d'ouvrir la
première case du calendrier de l'avent
mais annie poker va nous donner des
idées pour le réaliser soi même
bonjour mélanie bonjour camille je sais
pas je ne sais pas vous mais de mon côté
dès le début du mois de décembre j'ai
qu'une envie c'est d'être le 24 parce
qu'en général le réveillon c'est
l'occasion de se retrouver en famille
déguster un bon repas et découvrir les
cadeaux déposés pour le père noël
également pied du sapin
oui c'est ça qui fait que le plus dur
c'est d'attendre d'où le calendrier de
l'avent première question aussi camille
qu'est ce qu'on trouve dans le vôtre
alors moi je reconnais que j'ai opté
pour un calendrier de l'avent très
simple du chocolat pour faire classique
mais c'est vrai que dans le commerce
dans trouve de différentes marques des
différents dessins animés sous toutes
les sous tous les sigles si on peut dire
mais vous allez nous donner quelques
idées pour pouvoir en avoir un
personnalisé personnalisé c'est ça ces
mots ou voile résultats sur la table
j'ai pas fait les 24 des vingt-quatre
dates parce qu'il n'ya pas assez de
place mais il y en a bien sûr à faire
chaque jour du 1er au 24 décembre + gyr
oktay j'ai fait des cadeaux ça rappelle
les petits cadeaux du sapin ça fait
encore plus attendre la première étape
il faut trouver des patrons de quoi
faire soi même la boîte si ça correspond
pas à la taille de vos petits cadeaux
vous pouvez aussi de faire il faut
calculer ça fait un petit peu de
mathématiques aussi on sait jamais il
faut aussi choisir du papier cartonné
qui permettra de faire les boîtes
derrière un petit peu de souplesse c'est
plus facile pour plier on a moins de
surprise quand on a des toutes petites
mains quand on est un enfant du papier
cadeau pour emballer quelque chose qui
vous plaît joes coach de la colle des
ciseaux lassé des ciseaux un peu pointu
les enfants le bout rond ça passe très
très bien et pour numéroter les cadeaux
pour rappeler l'esprit du calendrier de
l'avent des petites étoiles de
différentes tailles et du coup vous
imprimez les patrons sur les feuilles de
couleur
ensuite vous les découper c'est ça on
découpe proprement parce que autrement
par dans des petites surprises aussi
quand on va plier après on puis chaque
trévise y voilà on sait ce qu'on voit à
l'image on fait ça calmement comme
chaque player permet meilleure boite et
ensuite vous collez vous scotcher tout
ça est la boîte est formé
mais surtout avant de la fermer
complètement qu'emi il faut surtout pas
oublier la petite surprise
alors justement des petites idées
cadeaux peut être a glissé dans l'est
dans ces boîtes alors moi j'ai choisi un
petit nounours ça rappelle ça permet
aussi de décorer le sapin ça fait
attendre encore plus noël des chocolats
des bonbons des petits jouets et si
jamais les enfants se décident de faire
un calendrier pour les parents pourquoi
pas des petits mots doux ça fait
toujours plaisir
il faut surtout penser à celui ou à
celle qui recevra le calendrier il ne
vous reste plus qu'à l'enveloppé d'un
beau papier cadeau du choix le même
différent et donc du coup on peut aussi
faire différentes tailles bien
évidemment là on envoie des plus gros
des plus petits et si on sache un peu au
niveau des idées
qu'est ce que vous nous conseillez a
deux solutions sont possibles la
première c'est tout simplement internet
le web regorge d'idées j'ai trouvé des
trucs super sympa on a des sapins en
papier on a des boîtes chinoise des
maisons histoire de recréer un vrai
village et même du bingo il s'agit de
chercher et de piocher l'a carrément au
hasard et puis pour ceux qui voudraient
un peu d'être il est aussi des ateliers
saint quentin n'est pas en reste il y a
à guyancourt au pont du rock thouars
samedi 26 nommant toutes les
informations de l'atelier sont à
retrouver sur le site de la commune
merci beaucoup mélanie poquet pour ses
idées de calendrier de l'avent qui on
l'espère vous aideront à patienter
jusqu'à noël en fête